hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt eine ganz besondere sonntags
torte und zwar habe ich einen orangen
weißen job weiße schokoladen torte
gemacht ich hab hier gut man sieht es
eigentlich im prinzip schon
ich hab mir einen schokoladen mantel um
die torte gelegt habt ihr orangen chip
selber hergestellt und das innere der
torte das wird euch faszinierend denn da
habe ich richtig viel frucht mit drin
auch mango mit drin und die torte ist im
prinzip nicht sehr schwierig sag ich mal
gibt ein paar einfache tricks die ich
euch jetzt auch gleich zeigen werde
und ich glaube da noch gar nicht was ich
drinnen verfehlt verwirrt ist ehrlich
ich hab schon nicht gesehen ich werde
mich auch aber wir werden jetzt zuerst
einmal den teig zubereiten damit einem
rohen teig gemacht und zeigt euch damals
schnell die programm wird den rohen teig
brauche ich drei eier 150 g zucker eine
prise salz 150 milliliter flüssigkeit
ich ein bisschen milch 150 milliliter
sonnenblumenöl etwas mannil extrakt 225
gramm mehl eineinhalb teelöffel
backpulver und eine orange ich nehme
jetzt die eier und zucker
das ist jetzt der alltagshektik auch
wirklich super einfach und sogar kommen
jetzt in eine rührschüssel gemeint
ein extrakt und dann muss ich die
mischung für etwa 4 bis 5 minuten
schaumig aufhören
die eier programme schon fertig und
jetzt kommen die zwei flüssigkeiten öl
und mint meter ziehen
ihr könntet ihr zum beispiel auch an der
stelle etwas orangenlikör zum beispiel
neben anderen auch den abruf von der
orange und deswegen muss sie eben auch
unbehandelt sein
die zutaten rede ich jetzt hier könnte
ein
jetzt vermutlich noch backpulver sieht
das dazu und dann werden die zutaten
noch kurz untergehoben
einfache sätze in der mini denn die hat
diese halbe stufe und dieses perfekte
unterheben
und jetzt will ich den teig in zwei
vorbereitete backformen und zwar mich
hier zwei tortenring mit 20 zentimeter
durchmesser
und die liegen hier auf dem temporären
bat mich also auf den lochblech
und zuteil geworden jetzt im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 160 grad bei
unserer hilfe für etwa 30 minuten backen
während die teige noch im backofen
backen kann ich jetzt schon mal die
orangen chips vorbereiten
dafür brauche ich nur drei zutaten und
250 gramm zucker 150 milliliter wasser
und zwei unbehandelten rauschte es
nämlich schon mal zucker und wasser und
die kommen in einen breiten topf und die
kann ich jetzt hier schon mal aufkochen
lassen und in der zwischenzeit die
orangen fein hobeln sind die entweder
seine küchen hobel also eine ganz
normale google oder nimmt ein scharfes
messer und können sie eben ganz schön
schneit aber so hat man es schön
gleichmäßig unsere stück brauche ich es
nicht
die zucker und wasser mischung müsse so
lange gekocht werden bis sich der zucker
aufgelöst
das geht gerade so 1 2 minuten jetzt
habe ich den herd weder ausgemacht und
lege jetzt die orangenscheiben hühner in
die sollten jetzt einfach komplett
bedeckt sein
dann können dass sie schon wieder
rausziehen
und die orangenscheiben nämlich dann
heraus las sie kurz abtropfen und legt
sie auf eine back folie und die liegt
auf einem backblech
die orangenscheiben versiert sind
backofen bei umluft getrocknet und zwar
hab ich den auf 130 grad vorgeheizt bei
den 80 zurück schalten oder brauchen sie
etwa zwei bis drei stunden
und während der bauzeit werde ich den
open immer mal wieder öffnen damit
einfach die feuchtigkeit entweichen und
die da drinnen wirklich gut
durchtrocknen
als nächstes werde ich jetzt die mango
füllung zu bereiten das ist ein manko
orangen chutney ein chutney ist
eigentlich etwas was man zum beispiel
auch ganz gut zu fleisch servieren kann
aber ich wette als füllung benutzen und
später mit etwas aktiver andenken für
das mango chutney brauche ich zwei reife
mangos zwei unbehandelte orangen 70
milliliter zitronensaft 100 gramm zucker
100 milliliter orangensaft oder ein
päckchen magazine nämlich zuerst einmal
dies bei mangos und die werden jetzt
geschält und dann in 1 cm würfel
geschnitten
i
b
als nächstes nämlich jetzt die zwei
orangen und schäle die also ich brauche
jetzt die orangenschale und es geht am
besten mit einem sparschäler und die
orangenschale kommt auch gleich mit ins
stadt nidda zu und damit die aber nicht
so bitter wird werde ich sie gleich in
wasser fünf minuten auskochen und gehen
einfach diese bittere stoffe bewegt und
einfach das tolle orangenaroma bleibt
mercedes auch mit dem sparschäler stellt
man nur diesen äußeren teil ab und die
weiße schale bleibt einfach weg ins
heiße wasser fünf minuten abkochen hohe
in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal
die orangen filetieren
das heißt oben durch den deckel
wegschneiden und dann am rand die weiße
haut weg
jetzt werden die filets rausgeschnitten
und zwar hier einfach an der haut
entlang und dann bleibt einfach diese
weiße haut übrig
die filets schneide ich jetzt ganz grob
die zerfallen später sowieso ein
bisschen und gibt sie dann auch in ein
schälchen und dieser rest hier die jetzt
weggeschmissen werden die drücke ich
jetzt auch noch aus
da ist nämlich noch ganz viele dachten
als nächstes nämlich jetzt den zucker
und gewinnen einen topf und der
defizitären karamellisieren
in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal
die orangenschale nehmen die es
abgekocht ist skeptisch ob das wasser
weg gegossen und wird jetzt klein
würfeln
den zucker lösche ich jetzt mit dem
zitronensaft das
zitronensaft kaltbad sich natürlich
jetzt ein großer karamell klug und
gebildet aber das ist gar nicht schlimm
da lässt sich gleich wieder gebe ich
auch die mango stücke mit rein und die
orangen und lass das ganze jetzt für
etwa zehn minuten bei mittlerer hitze
einkochen
das mango chutney es jetzt eingekocht
jetzt kann ich mich auch um die ak tine
kümmern
dafür gebe ich jetzt den orangensaft und
die aktiven in einem topf kann man
natürlich auch mit gelatine arbeiten
aber ihr wisst ich arbeite lieber mit
der vegetarischen alternative und wer
die ak schiene zwei minuten lang studie
und aufkochen lassen und während es hier
kocht kann ich in der zwischenzeit schon
mal die zeit böten hier herauslösen und
dafür nehme ich jetzt tortenring messer
als backform messe
und nach zwei minuten kann ich das jetzt
hier mit dem mango chutney verrühren und
dann wird es auch schön finden
damit hier die zweite bögen und werde
jetzt einen tortenring nehmender etwas
kleiner ist kann ich zum beispiel den
hier nehmen
seit ungefähr 16 der hier hat nur 12 je
nachdem wie hoch ihr die torte haben
möchte sollte jetzt einen kleineren oder
in grösseren nehmen und hier keiner der
durchmesser umso höher wird dann die
torte am ende mit den hier und stellen
auf ein stück papier oder
frischhaltefolie und fülle jetzt da das
chutney rein also die frucht anlage
und das lasse ich jetzt weil es noch
sehr heiß ist erstmal auf
zimmertemperatur abgekühlt und western
für etwa eine halbe stunde ins
gefrierfach stellen dass mein wirtschaft
also die frucht einlage sitz fest
geworden und ich werde es die
schokoladencreme zu bereiten
dafür stehen die zutaten schon mal da
und zwar habe ich da weiße schokolade
mit drin aber auch so ein bisschen säure
mit quark und schmand und des paars
geschmacklich wirklich sehr gut dazu
für die schokoladencreme frau ich 100
gramm weiße schokolade 400 milliliter
schwarz sage 200 vom spannend 500 gramm
magerquark etwas meinl exakt und seiner
partei und ich werde schon mal die
schokolade nehmen und über dem heißen
wasserbad schmelzen
das passiert jetzt hier das wasser darf
aber nicht kochen dass es ansonsten zu
heiß und kann es hier drüben schon mal
die schlagsahne nehmen und mit vier
teelöffel seiner partei schlagen
die sahne sitzstreik wir nämlich heraus
und in der zweiten schüssel habe ich
bereits quark und ich und gebe auch man
den extrakt und ein appartement dazu
das wird jetzt kurz verrührt und da muss
sie nur noch warten bis die schokolade
komplett geschmolzen ist
jetzt kommt die schokolade mit zur
quarkcreme wir müssen nur darauf achten
dass sie die creme ist nicht mehr zu
sehen auch wenn es gleich die sahne dazu
kommt damit sie eben nicht gewinnen
jetzt gehe ich hier noch die sache mit
rein dass es noch mal ganz kurz
die krimis ist schön fest und nehme
keine torten segel und werdet die beiden
böden ein bisschen durchschneiden damit
sie einfach perfekt gleichmäßig sind das
heißt oben den decken weg und den
brauche ich für die torte jetzt nicht
mehr den könnte aber zum beispiel
benutzen und später mit ein bisschen
creme vermischen cake pops oder einfach
ein kleines puzzle draus machen
jetzt nehme ich ein bisschen creme und
streicht den unteren boden
jetzt die frucht einlage dran und zwar
löse ich jetzt den torten
das aber am besten im tortenring hoch
und setzt es jetzt mit ich auf die torte
und jetzt setzt sich um einen tortenring
drumherum
die frau die jetzt eingeführt wird
jetzt fühle ich die creme hier noch in
die ränder ein können jetzt einmal mit
einem spritzbeutel machen zb begehen
diesen schneller oder nimmt einfach so
einen löffel
die creme streiche jetzt einen glatten
nehmen bisschen muss weg nur so zwei bis
drei esslöffel das brauche ich später
noch für die dekoration
hauptsache der frucht ist schön gedeckt
und das setzt sich jetzt den zweiten tag
machen auf
die torte deckel sitzt ab und stellen
sie für mindestens drei stunden in den
kühlschrank
jetzt stelle ich noch die letzte
dekoration für die torte her und zwar
habe ich dafür 200 gramm weiße kuvertüre
bereits gehackt und zwei drittel davon
über den heißen wasserbad geschmolzen
das heißt jetzt schon schön geschmolzen
und da gehe ich jetzt das restliche
drittel noch mit rein und temporäre
sozusagen die kur töre damit sie später
einmal schön fest wird kein grauschleier
bekommt und optimal zu verarbeiten ist
und die kuvertüre hat dann die perfekte
temperatur wenn jetzt hier die ganzen
respekt
die kultur ist bereit ich messe immer
gerne nochmal mit einem digitalen
schokoladen thermometer nach um etwa 28
29 grad hat ist weiße kuvertüre perfekt
und jetzt habe ich hier and backpapier
vorbereitet und zwar auf der rückseite
ein paar linien gezeichnet mit dem
abstand von 15 zentimetern
schließlich war die schokolade drauf
und für streicht sie mit einer palette
dass sich die kuvertüre hier kurz
anziehen und macht hier unten nochmal
einen streifen
und jetzt ist zum arbeiten ideal wenn
ihr eine marmor steinplatte habt habe
ich natürlich auch nicht deswegen weiß
ich mir zu helfen und nehmen einen
torten retter den hab ich jetzt kurz im
kühlschrank
so kann die kuvertüre etwas schneller
fest werden und ich möchte noch im
muster reinziehen das heißt ich nehme
jetzt die palette und streichelt hier so
kleine streifen rain
und so sind die streifen jetzt fast
fertig aber um zu leben ist ein hübscher
zu machen nehmen ein bisschen gold
pulver
es ist die kuvertüre bisschen fest
geworden ich hatte sie für eine minute
im kühlschrank und jetzt kann die
streifen zurechtschneiden und zwar erst
mal unten eine gerade fläche
und dann werde ich etwa 3 cm breite
streifen zurechtschneiden und die dann
einfach nur mal in den kühlschrank
stellen die torte eben auch so weit ist
jetzt kam der schönste bart ist lese ich
die torte aus der form heraus im bett
dekorieren
nämlich die reste creme die ich von
aufgehoben habe und streicht die auf die
oberfläche
jetzt nehme ich die schokoladen streifen
und die gebe ich jetzt hier am rand an
und wenn sie euch zu lang sind dann
klicken sie einfach ab oder brechen ab
oder schneidet sich die clips ein
bisschen überlappend aneinander
und jetzt kommen noch die orangen chips
raubtier sind jetzt auch richtig schön
durch getroffen hat sie ihr aufhören
können manchmal probieren probieren die
richtig cool
oleg oder die steck dir jetzt kurz vor
dem verzehr allerdings erst also kurzum
servieren nach oben reimer ansonsten
können sie einfach feucht werden
und wieder sind es ganz weit es kam also
essen kann
ich habe die zeit bringen so die sogar
so auf die torte hat schon mal klappt
super bio erreichen aber das so wir
machen ein bisschen zucker und jetzt
brechen fahrt durch und steck dir hier
noch so viel ruhe zu kommen
weil durch den zucker werden dir gut man
kann sie schon machen nur also ich merke
dass so wenig säuerlich bisschen von mir
reicht ja das finde ich gut
ja sie können im prinzip anordnen wir
jetzt möchte natürlich stand nicht die
pistole zum anschneiden als peter kohl
und wird so mache ich das ist kurz dann
darfst du gleich probieren kaffee dazu
kaffee kaffee latte
jetzt holte tel
und ich mache den kaffee ok wie
schneidet man jetzt diese torte an das
könnte sie in die kategorie sieht mega
hammer mässig aus aber man kann sie
natürlich nicht schön anschneiden
klar wenn man jetzt die orangen
schreiben ja immer ein café latte
macchiato
letzte vorgespannt ja halt die orangen
löffel geben so und es hört sich bisher
zu ihrer kollegin der wird staunen was
hier im innern drin
es wäre jetzt zwischengericht heiß
gemacht als ich mache das jetzt nicht
wunder denn da ihr danach durch sie
wieder drauf dass ich ganz ehrlich sagen
es sieht fast super toll aus aber zum
anschneiden natürlich sehr unpraktisch
ich weiß nicht was dann nicht wenn jetzt
zurück rauskommt für dich voll aus ihnen
folgen die wand
das ist einfach cool oder becken wie das
schmeckt man nur weiße schokolade also
ich finde es super hammer majors
ausschnitte soll ich noch also der teig
das richtig saftig
richtig cool ja gern schmeckt dieser
frucht mango orangen chutney so und das
außen ist eine quarkcreme okay ich mache
mir so ich immer ein bisschen von der
kunde von dem komplott hier und kompott
einfach
es hört sich nicht so toll an gerd ob
wir hier und hier ein bisschen mitnehmen
einfach lecker
man gleich noch das stückchen für das
bild ist so cool aus dem innern schmidt
und beispielcode und begeistert und guck
mal wie das innen aus mega cool oder
sind sehr schön
falls also ich finde eigentlich passt
die torte irgendwie netzer jahreszeit
aber eigentlich dachte ich auch heute
passt gut jetzt noch sommerlich aus aber
ich finde es trotzdem
ja auf jeden fall also ich finde auch
zimt wird richtig gut dazu passen
es gibt auf jeden fall noch drauf machen
und ansonsten finde ich sehr schön ist
der leckere torte nicht nur was ist euch
das an der schlink auf das weiße strikt
zu günstig wirklich das ist eine weiße
schokoladen mousse richtig dann den usa
zu essen und der teig ich auch richtig
doch das freute auch mein geburtstag
meint ein rührteig ja jedenfalls werde
ich es gleich noch die fotos machen also
wenn wir zusammen machen und das rezept
gibt's zum nachlesen auf sase - blog.de
und ich finde es echt super raffiniert
forte muss man natürlich ein bisschen
gut ich bin geübt auch wenn ihr die
tricks und tipps beachtet die ich euch
gezeigt habe gerade mit diesem
tortenring mit dem bisherigen dann
klappt das wunderbar und ich wünsche
euch ganz viel spaß für nachmachen und
wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal
dann tipps macht's gut und kommentiert
ich kommentiert
nein hat kann jemand meine kommentiert
wo wir unsere kinder bildung wahl
aufwachsen lassen
ich habe geschrieben irgendwie sind
keiner seite wachsen ganz normal
180 grad tue alles la murat die stars
dann tschüss
ich gehe jetzt eigentlich jetzt
einkaufen kann sprich ein bisschen
lustig mal ist es immer lustig wenn ich
dabei bin aber allein das tut mir leid
ich hoffe der clown kommt schuss kam
geht weiter